and now I'll mix the two together
yeah I'm on the last Indian boredom we
won't from the order one up from already
Oh ten days yeah okay thank you very
much for the introduction hello
everybody we give this lecture really to
try and inspire young people to consider
science and particularly chemistry so
this was a picture which was drawn by a
youngster when they were asked to tell
us what science was all about so when
we're doing the lecture we would advise
those particularly in the front twelve
rows it's away your safety glasses and
now I'll mix the two together in the
moment that they mixed you see that we
get this omission of luminescent light
and in this case it's a rather nice
fetching blue
which is to see if there the vessel
itself will rely to glowing splint so
there's a glowing splint
relight it really is the best experiment
that you ever did isn't it it's so
satisfying no nitrogen no water vapor in
the flat now we can add phosphorus
phosphorus is the Tiger of the periodic
table it's stored under water and here
we have a small amount tied onto a piece
of string so that I don't have to go
ferritin around with a spatula or
anything like that to get it out now the
energy required to start the combustion
of phosphorus in air is actually quite
low and in fact there's enough energy in
your fingertip as the scars on my
fingers all show so I'm not going to
touch it I'm just going to remove it
from the water and here you can see if I
leave it in the atmosphere it'll start
to smoke and I'm going to put it into
the flask before we lose control of it
so quite a hideous material it does
really fantastic chemistry now as I said
the activation energy required just
going to put the lights off the
activation energy required is very small
I could use the tip of my finger if it
was long enough but it's not so I have a
copper rod which I'm just going to heat
slightly in this flame and then across
the flask and let's see what happens
with this one
so I think you can see straight away
that that's a really really quite nice
chemical reaction you get in lots of
that really really bright white light it
looks fierce Oh doesn't it but it's cold
because what you're seeing is the
phosphorus pentoxide on the side of the
flask which is a phosphorescent compound
so it's getting excited and it's
phosphorescent there is a small amount
of phosphorus pentoxide coming out at
the top which is drying my throat
slightly and the strings actually
burning as well right this is a device
that we developed in jóska
it's called a match on a stick I think
it now has international renown are you
ready Neal okay so match on a stick to
cotton ball and oxygen I use water
because it acts a bit like suspension in
the back of your car and it means that
when the reaction reaches completion it
doesn't blow the bottom off my test tube
because it's quite energetic
so here we have for the barking dog okay
so now it's time for statistics yes
because to get all three to go really is
a miracle so here we have a custom
designed to test tube which again we've
got the same mixture carbon disulfide
n2o and a little bit of water pop it
back down into our favorite rocket tube
and again let's see if we can light this
one off so any of you that missed the
photograph opportunity for the other two
cross your fingers now where are we